[Musique]
salut à tous aujourd'hui je vous propose
de découvrir l'histoire d'euros maidan
le mouvement social ukrainien de l'hiver
2013 2014
un mouvement particulièrement
remarquable par certaines de ses
spécificités
d'abord il s'agit du seul mouvement de
protestation en europe ces dernières
années avoir entraîné la chute d'un
gouvernement et ensuite euros magdane
aura été un mouvement populaire et auto
organisés qui aura réussi à mobiliser
des citoyens et à faire vivre des
structures de lutte pendant trois mois
un exemple donc pour tous les
contestataires en herbe aussi dans cette
vidéo on verra mais dan un peu sous tous
ses aspects le déroulement du conflit en
lui-même bien sûr mais aussi sociologie
et quelques aspects organisationnels
mais tout d'abord pour bien comprendre
la situation fin 2013
faisons un petit point sur l'histoire
récente du pays
avant la période soviétique le pays n'a
jamais été unifiés le territoire étant
éclaté entre domination polonaise
autrichienne et russes donnant deux
cultures l'une tournée vers l'est et
l'autre vers l'ouest
des mouvements nationalistes
apparaissent dès les années 1910 et dans
les années 40
espérant s'affranchir de la tutelle
soviétique c'est nationaliste dirigé par
stéphane bern des rares salles iront aux
nazis et leur serviront de supplétifs
contribuant à faire de celui-ci une
figure controversée lors de
l'effondrement du bloc soviétique
le pays connaît une contestation
étudiante demandant la liberté politique
et économique appelée révolution sur le
granit consistant en une occupation de
la place de la révolution d'octobre
appelé ensuite place maïdan place de
l'indépendance dans les années 90 le
pays connaît une libéralisation
politiques et économiques chaotiques
générant une classe sociale monopolisant
à la fois le pouvoir économique et
politique
les oligarques en 2004 la présidentielle
oppose deux d'entre eux viktor
ianoukovitch vice premier ministre pro
russe et viktor iouchtchenko ancien
premier ministre pro européen lors de la
campagne
iouchtchenko est victime d'une maladie
inconnue lui laissant de fortes
séquelles au visage plusieurs experts
indépendants concluant à une tentative
d'empoisonnement à la dioxine
il faut dire qu'il est tombé malade
après un repas pris avec le dirigeant
des services secrets ukrainiens ce qui
attise les suspicions ianoukovitch
remporte la présidentielle sur des
soupçons de fraudes et d'appui de la
russie et iouchtchenko organisme
manifestation notamment sur la très
symbolique place maïdan qui déboucheront
sur la révolution orange à savoir un
second nouveau tour qu'il remportera
iouchtchenko élu il fait modifier la
constitution pour passer d'un régime
présidentiel fort à un régime plus
parlementaire la russie elle ne comptant
pas laissé l'ukraine lui échappe et
utilise alors l'approvisionnement en gaz
du pays comme moyens de déstabilisation
forçant la première ministre ioulia
timochenko a signé un accord sur le prix
du gaz défavorables à son pays
je vous passe pas mal de péripéties et
on arrive à 2010 ou ianoukovitch réussi
à remporter la présidentielle face à
timochenko
une fois au pouvoir ianoukovitch veut
ouvrir une enquête contre timochenko au
prétexte qu'elle a signé un accord sur
le gaz défavorable au pays
accor rappelons-le est signé sous la
contrainte après un procès politique et
dénoncé comme tel à l'international elle
écope de sept années de prison
ianoukovitch revient aussi à la
constitution hanté 2004 avec un pouvoir
présidentiel fort et tente de
verrouiller le système électoral à son
profit pour briser la dynamique de
l'opposition il fait voter une loi
interdisant les coalitions aux
législatives interdit les candidatures
indépendantes
hors parti et utilisent massivement les
médias publics au profit de son parti le
parti des régions fin 2013
au moment où commence notre histoire
l'ukraine est donc une jeune démocratie
qui se délite
maintenant venons dans iron maiden à la
fin du mois de novembre de cette
année-là le gouvernement ianoukovitch
est en train de boucler un accord de
rapprochement économique avec l'union
européenne
cet accord suscité l'espoir d'une partie
de la population qui y voyaient un moyen
de profiter d'amélioration économique
mais qui croyait aussi que cela
entraînerait un rapprochement avec les
standards européens en termes de
démocratie et de justice
clairement cet accord de libre-échange
cristalliser des espoirs un peu fou bien
au delà de son simple contenu mais le 21
novembre quatre jours avant la signature
le gouvernement a annoncé à la surprise
générale qu'il ne signera pas l'accord
des manifestations ont lieu le soir même
contre cette décision dans plusieurs
grandes villes dont kiev où le
rassemblement se fait place maïdan le
terme euros maidan apparaît dès le
premier jour pour nommer le mouvement le
lendemain les étudiants se mobilisent et
vont constituer l'épiné dorsale de la
contestation dans ce premier temps le
mouvement cristallise réellement le 24
novembre quand des citoyens de province
débarque à kiev pour une manifestation
pro union européenne prévue de longue
date à ce moment là deux pôles physiques
existent
un concitoyen occupant la place maïdan
et un autre sur une autre place
constitué des organisations politiques
les deux se rassemblent le 26 novembre
sur la place maïdan les politiques
acceptant de ne pas s'imposer tout en
apportant de la logistique comme la
grande scène centrale
d'ailleurs il est temps de faire un
point sur les forces politiques en
présence
face au parti des régions de
ianoukovitch vous avez trois partis
principaux
l'alliance démocratique pour la réforme
de vitali klitschko un ancien champion
de boxe la patrie le parti de ioulia
timochenko a dirigé à ce moment là par
arseni iatseniouk
tous deux étant des partis de
centre-droit libéraux conservateurs
pro-européens et svoboda le parti
d'extrême droite des radicaliser né au
passé sulfureux et se référant à stepan
bandera dirigé par oleg qui à une époque
à côté de ces grandes formations vous
avez aussi des groupuscules
ultranationalistes ayant parfois des
références néo nazis et dont certains
vieux militants ont combattu au côté des
indépendantistes tchétchènes contre les
russes dans les années 90 une partie de
ces groupuscules se réunira sous une
bannière commune dont on entendra
beaucoup parler
travis hector secteur droit dirigé par
dmitri yarosh et au passage petite
précision les drapeaux rouges et noirs
qu'on a pu voir sont des draps pour
nationaliste et non anarchiste ses
couleurs symbolisant le sang et le sol
pour la gauche très faible la situation
a été très compliqué dans un pays où
elle est facilement associer au passé
soviétique
une partie est issue de la tradition
stalinienne pro russe cette gauche-là a
combattu maidan le parti communiste par
exemple est allié au gouvernement
ianoukovitch
la nouvelle gauche l issue de l'ère
post-soviétique les anarchistes les
communistes n'ont stalinien les
féministes etc a été assez divisés les
revendications de maidan ne rentrant pas
dans sa grille de lecture habituel et
quand elle tenta de participer au
mouvement
les militants du rpt le faire en
individuel car sur la place les
tentatives d'implantation de tentes de
gauche ont été empêchés par zobda epr
avis hector en province elle a parfois
un peu plus de chances qu'à kiev et a pu
participer aux mobilisations
mais globalement la gauche est passé à
côté du mouvement voilà pour les
politiques
mais le mouvement de maidan a surtout
été un mouvement citoyen plusieurs
études sont venu le confirmer et
permettent de comprendre quels profils
se sont mobilisés
la grande majorité des participants
n'avaient pas d'appartenance qu'elles
soient politiques et syndicales ou
associatives au niveau de la langue
on retrouve à peu près les mêmes
proportions du créneau phone et de
russophones que dans
population même si la proportion du
créneau phone se renforce avec le temps
et au niveau social
on a surtout des citadins souvent jeunes
et une forte sur représentation des
classes instruite et des chefs
d'entreprise
le clivage entre pro et anti maidan
s'est donc pas fait sur des bases ethno
culturelle est plutôt sociale
globalement euros maidan aura été un
mouvement des classes moyennes urbaines
qui ne se voyait pas d'avenir si
ianoukovitch
d'ailleurs ici on ne parlera que de ce
qui s'est passé sur la place maïdan à
kiev mais des rassemblements avec
occupations de places ont eu lieu
ailleurs dans le pays surtout à l'ouest
où 80% de la population soutenait la
contestation est très peu à l'est où
seulement 8% des citoyens approuvé ce
qui se passait à meydan
mais au final ce qui s'est passé sur la
place maïdan à kiev
elle même ne représente qu'un tiers de
la mobilisation nationale est maintenant
revenons à notre histoire
après la phase initiale du 21 au 26
novembre
le soufflé retombe un peu les jours
suivants nombre de militants rentrant en
province après la manifestation pro
union européenne du 26 novembre dans la
nuit du 30 novembre au 1er décembre les
quelques centaines de contestataires
restant mobilisés sur la place surtout
des étudiants sont violemment expulsé
par les berkut la police anti émeute au
prétexte qu'il faut installer l'arbre de
noël sur la place
cet arbre ne sera d'ailleurs jamais
achevée et l'échafaudage servira à
construire la tour de drapeaux devenu
l'un des symboles du mouvement la
répression contre les étudiants alors un
effet mai 68 la violence contre les
jeunes remobilise radicalise et
massifier le mouvement le 1er décembre
un demi million de personnes manifestent
à kiev et les revendications évolué on
passe d'une demande de signature de
l'accord avec l'union européenne à une
demande de démission du gouvernement
ianoukovitch
phénomène nouveau des petits groupes
d'autodéfense avec des équipements de
fortune font leur apparition pour
protéger le camp contre les berkut la
mobilisation continue les jours suivants
et le 11 décembre la place maïdan est de
nouveau attaqué par la police et suite à
cet épisode des barricades vont être
érigés autour du camp qui va prendre des
allures de forteresse ce camp va être au
coeur de la contestation
d'abord d'un point de vue purement
politique la grande scène centrale
permet à tout à chacun de venir
s'exprimer
c'est également la conduit les concerts
et les meetings et puis l'occupation de
la place permet l'engagement des
citoyens
si certains sont chômeurs d'autres ont
carrément laissé tomber leur job ou
leurs études pour s'y consacrer à plein
temps
la plupart des militants viennent de la
province et dorment souvent dans des
tentes sur la place
regroupés par ville d'origine les quais
voient eux viennent lors des grands
rassemblements du week end ou après le
travail
les grands rassemblements dominicaux
pouvant réunir jusqu'à cent mille
personnes
la vie quotidienne s'organise de façon
auto des réer auto organisés et kyrielle
de groupes se créent pour prendre en
charge la logistique
certains sont deux micros groupes
affinitaires qui se créent au gré des
rencontre sur la place par exemple les
stands de ravitaillement où on prépare
et propose de tout sandwich au café ou
encore soupe à l'image du robot h un
groupe qui prépare du bortsch une soupe
slave pour plusieurs centaines de
personnes tous les jours
certains groupes sont plus conséquents
comme le service médical regroupement
des dizaines de personnes ayant souvent
une expérience dans le domaine
ce groupe avec d'autres occupent la
maison des syndicats qui donne sur la
place maïdan s'en servant comme puget et
hôpital de campagne mais disposant aussi
de plusieurs autres lieux occupés
reconverti en dispensaire on peut aussi
signaler un groupe d'automobilistes
appelé auto maidan qui aident à la
logistique au transport des manifestants
mais sert aussi à des actions
spécifiques en voiture comme le blocage
de véhicules de police ou les
patrouilles autour du camp auto maidan
lui aussi contre la corruption en
faisant des rassemblements devant les
domiciles des politiciens corrompus
parmi tous ces groupes on peut aussi
citer euros maidan sos qui fournit de
l'aide juridique aux personnes arrêtées
d'un point de vue de la structuration
politique tous ces groupes s'occupant de
la vie routinière duc en demandant au
nom des compétences spécifiques est
aussi petit soit-il sont importants il
permet à chacun à travers des routines
militante de s'impliquer de se sentir
partie prenante du mouvement et en fin
de compte permettent de souder les
participants autour d'une identité et
d'expériences communes
et puis à côté de tout cet aspect
logistique est un autre point
indissociable de maidan c'est la
question des groupes d'autodéfense créé
dès les premiers jours de la
mobilisation ils sont unifiés après
l'assaut policier du 11 décembre est
coordonné par un député de sloboda ces
groupes vont de 80 à 300 personnes et
vont jouer un rôle de plus en plus
important au fil du temps la situation
devenant de plus en plus violente cette
question de l'auto défense va permettre
au groupe d'ultra droite et par de
signifier sous la bannière de secteur
droit qui ensuite deux groupes
d'autodéfense se transformera en parti
politique
d'ailleurs petite parenthèse pour
évacuer le sujet secteur droit a servi
de repoussoir aux pro russe et
programmes lukovic pour dénoncer le
fascisme dont seraient porteurs euros
maidan il faut être clair c'est un
groupuscule qui a joué un rôle important
mais non décisif pendant la période
violente mais qui n'a aucune influence
politique
quand on regarde les parades qu'il
s'amusait à faire les phalanges de
secteurs droit c'est 200 à 300 personnes
guère plus sur les 4000 membres des
groupes d'auto défense
au plus fort des affrontements du métro
yarosh le chef du groupe a été candidat
au président
si elle suit à euromed dan en mai 2014
et a récolté 0,7 pour cent des voix
maidana est une révolution citoyenne et
tout le reste c'est de la propagande
russe et du journalisme à sensation
bref à partir du 11 décembre la
situation va se bloquer au niveau
institutionnel le gouvernement jouant le
pourrissement
pendant un mois la place va vivre à son
rythme toute l'infrastructure auto
organisés permettant de faire vivre les
5000 à 20000 personnes qui résident en
permanence selon les moments d'ailleurs
quelques mots sur l'origine de ce
fonctionnement
on l'a vu les protestataires sont plutôt
des classes moyennes de centre-droit et
ne peuvent donc pas se raccrocher à une
tradition de luttes de gauche pour
construire leurs pratiques comme c'est
souvent le cas dans les mouvements
sociaux
pourtant ce fonctionnement démocratique
photo organisé ne tombe pas du ciel
les militants de maidan puisent leurs
références leurs imaginaires dans
l'histoire du pays
l'ukraine est le lieu de naissance des
cosaques un peuple de guerriers réputés
pour leur esprit de liberté se passer
inspire fortement les protestataires
ainsi les unités d'autodéfense sont
appelés soutenir c'est à dire century en
référence au nom des régiments kozak
également des sociologues ukrainien
disent que maidan passe progressivement
d'un camp annecy tch ce terme désigne
les campements fortifiés kozak siège
militaire mais aussi politique où
s'exprimait la démocratie directe
les meetings du dimanche le où l'on
écoute les leaders mais où on prend
aussi part au vote pour décider de la
suite du mouvement sont appelés veche
terme renvoyant aux assemblées
populaires médiévale des pays slaves
on ne le dira jamais assez mais avoir un
imaginaire dans lequel puiser des
références et des pratiques est
fondamental pour faire vivre une lutte
bref un statu quo va s'établir pendant
de longues semaines maidan vivant à son
rythme et le gouvernement ne lâchant
rien aux contestataires
la situation va finir par se débloquer à
la mi janvier 2014 soit six semaines
après le début du conflit n'arrivons pas
à éteindre la contestation le
gouvernement fait adopter le 16 janvier
une série de lois répressives surnommé
loi dictatorial clairement anti
démocratique interdisant les
rassemblements publics et manifestations
le parti communiste apporte sa pierre à
l'édifice en proposant que la
dégradation de monuments liées à la
période communiste soient condamnées au
final ce sont toutes les activités et
type de mobilisation liée à maidan qui
sont criminalisés par ces lois et
plusieurs dizaines de personnes arrêtées
risquent ainsi jusqu'à 15 ans de prison
pour trouble
public tout cela ne fait que renforcer
la mobilisation mais lui donne aussi un
tour plus radicale un point de non
retour est franchie le dimanche 19
janvier après le classique meeting et
dominical réunissant tout de même 100
mille personnes est axé autour de la
dénonciation des nouvelles lois sur une
idée d'un dirigeants d'otor maidan
plusieurs dizaines de milliers de
manifestants se dirigent vers le
parlement situé à proximité de là mais
sont arrêtés par les berkut à quelques
encablures du bâtiment rue rousseff qui
le face-à-face dégénère en affrontement
général des cars de police sont
incendiés et serviront de frontières
entre les deux camps et les
affrontements resteront sporadiques dans
la zone jusqu'au 22
date à laquelle les berkut donnent
l'assaut faisant trois morts dont deux
par balle plusieurs profils participent
à ces affrontements des hooligans des
militants de base d'euros maidan et les
centuries d'autodéfense parmi lesquels
secteur droit se montre très actif ces
jours là dans cette période la
répression dérape les berkut utilise des
canons à eau
alors qu'il fait un froid glacial le
pouvoir recrute des cogneurs surnommé ti
touche qui pour agressé et tabassé les
militants voire pire des actions
d'intimidation ont lieu contre les
membres d'auto maidan des véhicules sont
incendiées mais surtout des militants
sont enlevés et torturés comme dmitro
boulatov le leader du groupe qu'on ne
retrouvera qu'une semaine après sa
disparition
également le 21 janvier deux militants
sont enlevés à l'hôpital l'un d'eux sera
retrouvé vivant le lendemain dans une
forêt l'autre trop affaibli et retrouvé
mort de froid et tous les deux
présentait des signes de tortures moins
grave mais fort symboliquement miraelaw
gavriil yacht lui un membre des groupes
d'autodéfense est forcé par les berkut
de se déshabiller en public par -15° ces
événements du 19 au 22 janvier marque un
tournant
l'idée que seule la violence peut
débloquer la situation commence alors à
s'imposer dans l'esprit des
contestataires
signe que la protestation devient
insurrectionnel maidan se militarise et
d'aytré y apparaissent également des
bâtiments publics sont occupés à kiev
mais aussi dans le reste de l'ukraine
dans cette période
les trois chefs des partis de
l'opposition perdent aussi de leur
influence ainsi voulant s'opposer à une
action violente
vitali klitschko est aspergé à coups
d'extincteur après deux mois sans
résultat concret leur crédibilité qui
reposait sur leur capacité à faire
remonter les revendications de maidan
est mise à mal
et alors que la situation était bloquée
depuis deux mois du 23 au 30 janvier les
choses évoluent extrêmement rapidement
les chefs de l'opposition négocient une
trêve et des pourparlers sont entamés
avec le pouvoir bien que de façon assez
chaotique
ainsi le 23 janvier et leader de
l'opposition présente aux protestataires
rassemblés sur la place un plan négocié
impliquant de libérer la rue ou chez
free et des administrations contre la
libération de prisonniers l'assemblée
qui demandent la fin de ce qu'elle
considère être une dictature refuse ses
maigres concessions et les insultes
fusent contre les négociateurs le
pouvoir tente alors des manoeuvres
désespérées en proposant à hearts et
gnocchis klitschko les postes de premier
et vice premier ministre poste que les
intéressés décline les 28 et 29
le gouvernement capitule enfin si
ianoukovitch reste en place le premier
ministre lui démissionne le parlement
abroge les lois dictatorial et votent
une loi amnistiant les militants
emprisonnés qui prendra effet quinze
jours après que les protestataires
libéré les administrations publiques
le geste trouve cette fois un écho parmi
les pros maidan et entraîne l'évacuation
de larouche et ce qui est de certaines
administrations
suite à cela la situation se calme et
une désescalade a lieu jusqu'au 18
février
ce jour là le parlement doit débattre du
retour à la constitution de 2004 et
choisir un nouveau premier ministre
cinq mille manifestants se rendent
devant le parlement pour mettre la
pression mais là les berkut appuyés par
des petites touches qui les attendent et
la manifestation tourne à l'affrontement
faisant plusieurs morts les
protestataires se replie sur la place
maïdan et dans la soirée et subissent
l'assaut des berkut dans la bataille de
nuit qui s'ensuit à force d' usage de
grenades et de cocktails molotov
une partie du camp et de la maison des
syndicats qui sert toujours de qg aux
protestataires sont victimes d'incendiés
les affrontements du 18-19 font une
vingtaine de morts et des centaines de
blessés
ces événements relancent la contestation
dans toute l'ukraine et des bâtiments
publics sont de nouveau occuper le vin
les violences reprennent et atteignent
leur paroxysme
la place n'est plus qu'un immense champ
de bataille à moitié brûlé les
affrontements sont massifs et
particulièrement sanglant les deux camps
utilisant sporadiquement des armes à feu
et les snipers des forces spéciales
étant particulièrement meurtriers
plusieurs dizaines de personnes perdent
la vie ce jour-là et au total sur trois
mois plus d'une centaine de
protestataires ont trouvé la mort et
seront considérés comme de véritables
martyrs appelé century céleste ces
événements signe la chute du régime et
son abdication complète devant les
revendications de maidan le 21 et le 22
les leaders de l'opposition ont signé un
accord avec le gouvernement incluant le
retour à la constitution de 2004
l'amnistié pour les prisonniers et un
amendement grassi même ioulia timochenko
qui est libérée dans la foulée mais les
protestataires veulent toujours la tête
de ianoukovitch et le 21 au soir lors de
l'hommage aux morts
un jeune protestataire intervient sur la
grande scène et exprime le sentiment
général menaçant de déloger le président
par les armes s'il ne partait pas
immédiatement les faits et radicale et
le lendemain ianoukovitch fille en
russie
laissant le pouvoir vacant les
ukrainiens investissent alors sa
somptueuse propriété découvre son train
de vie délirant un nouveau président est
élu en mai 2014
l'oligarque petro porochenko rester en
retrait jusque là mais ayant aidé
financièrement le mouvement également
certains citoyens rendus célèbres par
leur engagement accéderont par la suite
à des postes politiques comme miraelaw
gavriil uk qui sera élu député ou demi
trop boulatov qui sera ministre des
sports exemple parmi d'autres la suite
malheureusement on la connaît l'est qui
soutenait majoritairement ianoukovitch
fait sécession avec l'appui de la russie
entraînant une guerre civile mais tout
cela ne relève plus de notre histoire de
meydan histoire qui j'espère vous aura
passionné comme elle m'avait passionnés
à l'époque
si c'est le cas n'hésitez pas à partager
cette vidéo et pour ma part il ne me
reste plus qu'à vous dire à la prochaine